[Music]
did you find him I found something
so it's true Superman is alive
well alive is a strong term we don't
have time for this
tell me what's going on Diana he's he's
oh god Zak I'm sorry I can't do this
this is a terrible idea
what do I pay you people for Zach you
don't pay us that's right we do what
does the studio wat now
your ideas are polarizing our audience
mr. Schneider we need you to play it
safe here
be funny very funny people love Joe lots
of jokes
what do you think Ben uh yeah jokes
can't be good as long as we use it the
right time you see Ben agrees with us
and some of his films have won Oscars
you know what I'm done for the day you
think you can do a better job huh Fred
boy bony Bob Turk I know Percy your
daughter need you but I need you here we
have a crisis on our heads
now don't dress someone
they don't know what they're talking
about people love my ideas the twist of
this next one's gonna change everything
come on up ooh how COO of cool who's
there
so there bang I come back to warn you
it's not too late too late for what to
change your ways you must not make the
same mistakes I did your career can
still be said are you a ghost
yeah but you're not dead dude just go
okay tonight you will be haunted by
three spirits who keep their word do as
they say your career kids do these days
anyway you want to get some a please or
something goodbye Zak hi what the hell
just happened
where am I hell are you I'm the ghost to
your past sack on the side of 300
alright your art now this is gonna be
just like it is in the books
you're gonna ring back and boot this guy
to his death you're gonna yell the line
and it'll be great don't you think it's
a little bit over the top I'm not sure I
can pull it off you can Gerard
because I believe in you this is going
to be an iconic moment
[Music]
I like this guy yeah me too I don't know
what it is but he is cool yeah they
liked me hey Zack I got a great idea
that could make this scene even better
hey why can't they hear me I'm only
showing you what was you can't change
your past Zack but you can change your
future look how well you treated them
believed in them and they believed in
you you stayed true to the characters
you were representing and you didn't let
your ego get in the way of that I
[Music]
remember ready it's time to go Zack
I want to stay please let me stay
this is sparta
weird day cherry cherry but Jessie nope
the names Lex Luthor I need alcohol
[Music]
surely you remember your greatest
alteration I was your best idea ever
until this new Justice League game
changer you've been talking about you
want my opinion
no all right everybody's AK daddy is
back then hit the bricks personally get
my works go they can't hear you will you
stop that I'm the ghost of your present
Zack this is all happening right now but
I'm the only one that can see and hear
you
okay how about we cut page 15 altogether
and instead of your first line on page
16 you just go ahead and give him one of
those Wonder Woman players that's a
great idea
good thinking Ben oh what a hack Argo
sucked Thank You Percy don't you go
ahead and take 30 mr. Staunton uh give
me break
mr. Schneider's not here right now glad
it's okay what the hell does he think he
is this is ridiculous I made you I saved
you from daredevil you ungrateful
bastard
we need a plan of action
the studio isn't doing very well and
Zack just isn't working we think it best
to change the DC lineup perfume or team
Upton before Justice League Alfred and
Jimmy Olsen crypto swampthing Ares and
the Plastic Man
any suggestions
Jeff what if we do a couple of solo
movies to build up some of the bigger
characters first no the chart says no no
this is all Rob this can't be all my
fault it's not but you haven't exactly
helped matters either who's there
[Music]
our next item is this Burton helmet from
his first big hit film do I hear a
nickel I give you three cents third god
bless you sir who are they talking about
is this stupid looking shirt cool
do I hear a dime I'll give you a penny
for it
sheesh if you like him being ripped off
how about a penny and this rusty button
it's really a shame the way things
turned out this is almost as sad as the
day number two died I felt like half an
executive ever since what were they
talking about
oh thank god there's just some guards
next I look at this be what caused this
[Music]
no that's impossible savvy Superman is
my first idea ever
it was gonna be a game-changer
[Music]
this is our rod look I promise I'll make
Justice League good okay I promise I'm
too
[Music]
I bet my bad guys I'm back Zack you're
only gone for like 20 minutes
then you beautiful fool I love Argo yeah
have you been working out because you
look jacked
Percy what have I told you about taking
breaks take as long as you need buddy I
know you got to go be with your daughter
so why don't you just take the rest of
the week off mr. Schneider you're so
generous tiny town say thank you mr.
Schneider god bless us every yeah yeah
we know kid give her whatever she wants
I got a meeting to catch
[Applause]
guys I don't things are little hectic
right now but this isn't how we handle
our problems I'll admit it I haven't
been easy as kind of work with it some
of my ideas a bit so radical lately but
the same goals for how you've all
handled the situation it's time we put
our differences aside and work together
we're making movies about some of the
most popular characters in history
people have loved it for decades it's
time we start treating them with respect
they deserve
sad about making them edgy or hip to the
jive man it's about being true to why
these characters are so beloved in the
first place I can see that down I'm
ready to accept it so what do you say
are we a team
Thank You Zack that was beautiful yeah
we we really needed to hear it in the
interest of working together as a team I
think we can compromise on your ideas so
we're behind you 100% I'm your biggest
one yet we get it these types of
characters are very popular right now
and you started your career with them
wait what are you guys talking about
[Music]
hey everybody hope you enjoyed that
brand new episode of the Snider ring a
Christmas Snider ring everybody here at
awesome comics worked really really hard
to put that one together for you guys so
I hope you liked it I wanted to announce
right here right now that we will be
taking next week off so in two weeks
when we return we will have brand new
episodes brand new things to discuss
brand new topics to talk about so I hope
you guys join us for that and everyone
here are some comics again wanted to say
Merry Christmas Happy Hanukkah happy
holidays happy New Year and we will see
you in the future
2017 bye everybody